well let's get Labor's take on all of
that now shall we we're joined by the
shadow Chief secretary to the treasury
Department Fadden thank you very much
for being on the program uh today
um I know you were across the James
cleverley interview what's your reaction
to it
well look I wish we were talking about
other things
um you know we might do as well things
to say yesterday about the cost of
living crisis and energy bills and so on
uh
I think the problem with these things if
you take these different stories
together is that it's very easy for the
public to conclude they're all the same
they're all in it for themselves and I
think with the Boris Johnson stuff
he almost relies on that level of
cynicism so that people conclude no
Scandal matters nothing matters because
that's what they're like anyway and I
feel more than the individual cases this
is really corrosive to governance and
government or a big problem space in the
country we need good government and I
think it's it'd be a tragedy if the
result of all this was for people to
just simply turn away from politics and
say they're all a bunch of crooks and
needs now in important to say Boris
Johnson spokesperson says a story is
rubbish that Richard Sharp didn't give
me any Financial advice there hasn't
been any remuneration for Richard Sharp
you've reported Boris Johnson to the
Parliamentary commissioner for standards
uh why have you done that
we've done that because we think this
needs to be looked into Boris Johnson's
spokesperson said so what big deal which
actually sums up his whole response to
all of these things over the last couple
of years on the specifics of this the
allegation is that the chairman of the
BBC acted as a broker to uh help
facility are a loan of 800 000 pounds to
Boris Johnson while he was a candidate
to become the chairman of the BBC that's
not just labor that said this we
understand the cabinet office actually
intervened to say that this Arrangement
couldn't continue because he was a
candidate to become chairman of the BBC
so obviously that big big questions
about what was going on here and that's
why we've made that reference now
Richard Sharp says that there wasn't a
conflict of interest we heard James
cleverley there saying that Richard
Sharp is a man of you know great
integrity that he understands why he was
given the role
is the BBC impartial
well look
you know I'm not here to the popular BBC
but I do think it's pretty extraordinary
if someone who is running to be the
chairman ends up acting as a broker to
help the prime minister of the day out
of whatever financial difficulties he
was in at the very least that should all
have been declared and brought into the
open there's nothing in Boris Johnson's
Declaration of Interest as an MP about
this
it's been brought into the open by
journalism not by people being
transparent and that's why I do think
this does need to be looked into okay as
you say
um you're calling from the investigation
they say uh that the story isn't uh
accurate so we'll see how that goes
um let's talk about Nadeem zahawi uh
shall we um James cleverly says that he
will survive tool prime minister's
questions on Wednesday what's your take
I think it's difficult for uh Mr zahawi
because the the problem with this is
what we've been asked to believe and
uh we've been asked to believe that he
had this asset worth 27 million pounds
that he didn't really know was his and
effort and we know uh tax was due on it
and the thing about his statement issued
yesterday is he was using pretty heavy
legal letters to try to get people to be
quiet about this back in July
to don't need all the tax expert who
exposed some of this to newspapers like
the independent threatening legal action
and then we're asked to believe that
it's all just carelessness that doesn't
quite fit so I think this is quite
difficult for them now
um Rishi sunak is there a question mark
about
he knew James cleverly said look I don't
know anything about this all I know is
what is in the deem zahawi's statement
and but he's obviously you know cabinet
minister he's a part of chairman under
Rishi sunak it's a problem for the Prime
Minister too well I think it is because
when he came into office he promised a
new broom and all this that after the
Boris Johnson days when proprietary in
ethics had been in the news almost every
day through one Scandal or another
uh that he would you know turn over our
new Leaf to be a new page and so on so I
think this is a test of that uh and if
you've got someone who is negotiating
all this while he was the chancellor
threatening people with uh legal action
and then coming to the conclusion that
uh he's owed millions of pounds uh to
the to the tax uh man and probably with
a penalty in it as well we we don't know
for sure but it looks that way
I think this is a question for the Prime
Minister as well because what does that
New Broom that turning the page on the
propriety and ethics questions mean if
this is just Shrugged off and we should
say of course new teams are how we
statement Point towards his statement
yesterday where he says that his taxes
are you know now up to date that he
reached the settlement with hmrc to do
that
do you think that actually we're getting
to a stage now where high profile
politicians should actually just publish
their tax returns maybe they should I've
got no problem with that
um what what concerns me more about us
is what I said at the beginning that the
public will just conclude everybody's
utter in some way well that's the way to
to counter that though right
transparency it may be on tax as I said
you know I would have no problem with
that but these scandals are not just
about tax returns with Boris Johnson
question that we're discussing today is
about something else what I'm more
concerned with is that people give up on
politics and that would be really bad
for the country because there are plenty
serious issues that need good governance
and need politics to address them the
cost of living crisis is one the
situation in the NHS is another there is
plenty to be doing here and I don't want
people to think politics can't have any
solutions because they're all in it for
themselves well let's talk about some of
those serious issues now uh shall we and
the NHS she mentioned we of course seen
the strike action from nurses and
ambulance workers too we'll be talking
to unite Sharon Graham shortly
nurses have signaled that they would
accept a pay rise of around 10 would
labor grant that
I've been doing interviews on this for
three months and every time a journalist
has asked me what's the percentage I've
had to point out this has got to be
negotiated between the employers the
government and the union I'm not going
to give a percentage today the important
thing is that staff in these sectors get
a decent pay rise then because these
straights generally what what do you
think is a decent payment well this you
know it has to be negotiated I'm not
going to give us a figure but you just
said that staff need to be given a
decent pay literally what is a DC well
that's got to be negotiation inflation
that's got to be negotiated around the
uh the table
obviously it has to be negotiated that's
clearly a fact but I just wonder you
know if you say that journalists have
been asking you this question for three
months do you think that's because we're
not getting an answer we don't know what
label we give is a fair pay rise two
percent is it fair pay raise 12 I could
name any percent you want to do yeah
that'd be great actually thank you 20 50
and the fact is because we're in
opposition it doesn't get the nurses an
extra point it might do a lot to help
them if labor came out with a policy no
labor coming out with a percentage
doesn't make any difference to these
strikes what would make a difference in
the longer term as a government a really
backed public services and that's what
we did when we were in government we
didn't have these uh strikes we managed
to give people both decent pay Rises and
fund the Public Services properly and
that's what we'll do if we get elected
because
it's a problem if you're from the public
services properly then would you be
prepared to give more money to the NHS
the problem for the NHS is not just the
current industrial dispute the problem
for the NHS is that even when there
isn't a straight day we've got 7 million
people on waiting lists so what we've
said is Staffing us at the heart of this
we need to train more doctors we need to
train more nurses we need to change the
way the system works our ambition isn't
just to save this service is to renew it
for the future we've said how we'll do
that we've said how we'll fund that
there's got to be a longer term solution
to Public Services other than just a
short-term ambition to get through the
strikes sure but I guess what the nurses
Unions would say is that it's not just a
short-term ambition this is all about
the workforce right and the people feel
that they're not getting paid a fair
amount then they're going to leave which
is what's happening right now they've
got a recruitment crisis and I have to
say you know labor say look you know we
get around the table and negotiate we
would be given Fair Deal to nurses but
if you look at the actual meat of what
you're saying
I can't work out how it's different from
the government because you won't put a
figure on on what you do
I figured from my position would be
pretty meaningless because we're not a
party to the negotiations when we were
in government we managed to negotiate
decent payorises for NHS staff and fund
the service properly you know these days
they're talking about an ambition of
getting a GP appointment in two weeks
when we were in office it was within 48
hours that's the difference that can be
made but I've got to also be honest with
your viewers
after 13 years a situation that we
inherit won't be thunder and overnight
it will take time to rebuild the NHS and
that's why we've put this issue of
Staffing and training more doctors and
nurses at the heart of our proposals
because there is no solution to the
long-term problems of the NHS without
addressing Staffing p is an issue of
course it's an issue with inflation
running at the levels it is today it's
not just about pay it's about short
staffing on Wards it's about waiting
lists with just not enough people in the
service to deal with them so we need to
deal with that and renew the NHS so that
it can really be the 21st century Health
Service that we need okay thank you very
much for being on the program at this
moment pattern there for the labor party